well there's been so much going on
obviously it's been easy to forget it
but there is still a presidential
campaign going on this year until a few
hours ago in fact the Democratic
primaries were still in progress but now
it's done at least officially this
morning Bernie Sanders dropped out of
the race we are now some 300 delegates
behind Vice President Biden and the path
toward victory is virtually impossible
and so today I am announcing the
suspension of my campaign so that's it
for Sanders he's 78 years old he will
never be the president but he did leave
his mark for two cycles in a row Bernie
Sanders evoked panic at the highest
levels of the DNC twice in a row
Democratic Party leaders managed to
crush him in the end and they did that
despite the fact that Sanders had a
large and passionate following as well
as a genuinely populist message the DNC
meanwhile is ossified and corrupt and
cares not at all about the actual lives
of its voters so how did they manage to
beat him twice well they couldn't have
done it without Sanders his help Sanders
never wanted to win like so many
ideologues he wanted to lose it makes
him feel virtuous in 2016
Sanders wouldn't attack Hillary Clinton
for putting classified email at risk on
an unsecured server he didn't go after
the grotesque scam that was the Clinton
Foundation until it was far too late to
matter
this year he disavowed one of his own
supporters for criticizing Joe Biden and
then floridly praised Biden's character
then Sanders sat by like an embarrassed
child as Elizabeth Warren in CNN
attacked him as a sexist after a while
voters began to wonder the obvious if
the Democratic Party isn't bad enough
for Sanders to attack it then why do we
need a revolution Sanders never answered
that question and now he never will
because underneath it all he was a party
man to the core always said all of which
means Joe Biden is now the presumptive
Democratic nominee nobody really chose
Biden for this job he wound up in it by
a series of defaults and it shows ask
yourself is Joe Biden ready to lead this
country could he find his car in a
three-tiered parking garage could he
navigate a salad bar and by the way what
exactly is his position on the corona
virus pandemic those are the mysteries
Democrats now face
button has been virtually invisible for
the last month that's not an accident
Joe Biden on camera means more moments
like this we cannot let this we've never
allowed any crisis from the Civil War
straight through to that pandemic is 17
all the way around 16 we have never
never let our democracy
sakes second fiddle way that we can both
have a democracy and elections and at
the same time corrective Public Health
you follow that correct the public
health it's hard to imagine a man like
that making it through a presidential
debate or even staying awake through the
inaugural proceedings it seems likely
that at some point Democratic leaders
will try to find a way to replace Biden
before the November election Andrew
Cuomo is the obvious replacement but
there are many others whatever happens
it's worth taking Joe Biden seriously
for this moment now that he is
officially in a sense the nominee Biden
was first elected to the Senate in 1972
that was the other Richard Nixon open
China to the west as the threat from
trying to grew larger and more
threatening much more obvious over the
decades Biden seemed to grow more
accommodating to the Chinese government
in 2000 for example the us-china trade
relations act gave China normal trade
status what does that mean well in her
book China rx rosemary Gibson who we've
had on the show details how that piece
of legislation opened the floodgates for
Chinese drug imports within three years
of the bill passing America lost its
last aspirin factory its last vitamin C
facility its last penicillin plant our
ability to make critically vital
antibiotics in this country vanished and
that was a serious blow to our national
security and yet Joe Biden voted for
that bill he went on to oppose
amendments to it they would have put
pressure on China to release political
prisoners and stop forced abortions 11
years later in 2011 Biden still didn't
see the threat in fact he appeared to
welcome it that year he said quote a
rising China is a positive development
not only for China but for America the
day that Biden gave that speech millions
of Americans that already lost their
jobs they've been shipped overseas to
China Chinese students were already
flooding America's schools and research
labs crowding out Americans stealing the
data in information in the end
would boost the Chinese economy to where
it stands today larger than ours it's
hard to leave Biden said that but it
wasn't the only time he did here was
Biden last May on the campaign trail
China is going to eat our lunch come on
man they're not bad folks folks but
guess what they're not a competition for
us just two months ago when it was
already clear to everyone who was
watching that China had lied to the
world in ways that hurt the world about
a deadly outbreak of the Wuhan
coronavirus Biden was still flacking for
the Chinese government watch this no we
have right now a crisis with the corona
virus emanating from China in moments
like this this is where credibly a
president is most needed as he explains
what we should and should not do this is
no time for Donald Trump's record of
hysteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia - and fear-mongering
- lead the way instead of science the
xenophobia it seems almost antique why
because in a moment like this in a
moment of national crisis irrelevant
issues tend to recede you probably heard
a lot less recently about how America is
racist how we need reparations for
slavery or non-binary signs in every
public men's room stall
it all seems insulting ly frivolous now
what matters in moments like this are
the big things and at the top of that
list is who should lead this world going
forward should it be the United States
or should it be the government of China
anyone who has trouble answering that
question probably won't be the president